[Música]
[Aplausos]
que no se nos viene a la mente cuando
hablamos de innovación
un drone innovación tecnología
el cambio que tiene desde el primer
drone hasta el de ahora los usos
desde traer el mercado a casa desde
hacer cine desde supervisión de obras
desde sacar las topografías desde llegar
a los lugares donde nunca hemos llegado
es el cambio de la tecnología que le
hemos visto y ahora que veía el otro día
está llevando gente de un lado a otro
la revolución de la máquina 3d es una
innovación
poder tener el material eficiencia ha
dado una vuelta al mundo en el sentido
que si se me rompe algo de la licuadora
no necesito botar la licuadora si no me
puedo bajar el repuesto imprimirlo y
ponerlo
lamentaría materialidad y el cambio
entonces podríamos decir que innovación
es tecnología que es eficiencia y que es
diseño
esto también es innovación tenemos
tecnología tenemos eficiencia y tenemos
diseño
las soluciones locales también son
innovaciones acá podemos ofrecer lo que
es nuestro producto las naranjas el área
de trabajo lo tengo restringido sé donde
trabajo como corto reciclo saco lo que
he sacado lo pongo en un lado ofrezco el
producto lo tomo reciclo en el otro lado
y si hace mucho calor tengo una
sombrilla para taparme
tengo una caja abajo donde puedo guardar
lo que he ganado
cierro y me lo llevo y como pueden ver
tengo hasta el lugar para mi silla
esto también es innovación
a finales del 2020 de este año el perú
bolivia se sube a la red global más
grande del mundo con los laboratorios de
aceleración
qué son los laboratorios de aceleración
nos preguntaremos no somos financiadores
de startups los ejemplos que hacemos
aquí es acelerar el impacto
y ustedes sabían que acelerar el impacto
lo venimos haciendo hace miles de años
desde las comunidades que podrían hacer
fuego
desde que cómo resolvían la estructura
para soportar algo de cómo caminaban o
cómo resolvían sus problemas las propias
comunidades
eso es inteligencia colectiva
esta imagen es entender que todas las
abejas van los contextos son distintos
pero el final siempre todos llegan
tenemos la colmena se salen todas vuelan
todos tienen distintas áreas y después
vuelven
la inteligencia colectiva ahora más que
nunca ha tomado mucho valor porque por
la tecnología hoy podemos ver las ideas
de todo el mundo podemos conectar las
podemos sistematizar las y podemos ver
qué datos tenemos
es ahí donde el laboratorio nos
preguntamos y decimos
como la gente se está comunicando con
esto de la pandemia
como están resolviendo sus problemas
cómo se llaman como se unen como tienen
la relación con sus
pares con las alcaldías
como están viendo y ahí se hace un
trabajo de inteligencia colectiva
sentada al primero con la alcaldía en
decir que está pasando cómo podemos
acelerar cómo podemos resolver este
problema cómo podemos entender y nos
decían todo tranquilo no se preocupe
estamos hablando con el presidente del
bar
pero le seguía el presidente como se
está viendo con todos cómo hacemos esto
usted y caemos en un barrio el barrio
san sebastián en el borde de la paz y el
alto donde comenzamos unos trabajos de
inteligencia colectiva donde comenzamos
a analizar y les decimos primero cómo
están cómo va todo y obviamente la
primera fase era crítica
demandas críticas
preocupaciones pero comenzamos a hablar
con ellos para ver cómo eran las
soluciones que ellos tenían
las soluciones que ellos mismos hacían
ya y saltaban cosas impresionantes a
doña magaly abriendo la puerta de su
living comedor para que entren los diez
niños que no podían ir al colegio porque
los papás tenían que ir a trabajar en la
enfermería y ella les abría la puerta
porque tenía el internet y los chicos
podían estudiar
o el grupo de 15 o 18 mujeres que
comenzaron a trabajar y hacerse cuotas
de un pasanaku
para poder llegar a fin de año hacer un
canastón venderlo y ganar y poder
subsistir
e identificar que nos decían que
personas mayores están en el barrio
y ahí llegamos porque hablo todo en
nosotros porque esto es la co-creación
nosotros comenzamos a trabajar con ellos
no llegamos con ningún estándar de esto
se hace
tenemos que aprender que aquí están las
soluciones y ustedes las están dando y
demandando
pasan dos a tres semanas y cuando
volvemos a la dirección y era de jóvenes
las señoras que habían estado con
nosotros toman el mando del bar
actualmente es el barrio digital número
uno en bolivia
se ha trabajado con ellos lo que son
encuestas se les ha explicado para que
si en una encuesta para qué sirve tener
los datos de las personas hemos evaluado
con ellos cómo podemos ofrecer algo más
en el área privada con las distintas
capacitaciones que ellos pueden tener en
el tema de financiamientos de entender
cómo ahorrar en las siguientes etapas y
en la segunda es en la parte pública
cómo pueden tener relación directa con
las alcaldías cómo pueden subir sus
datos y saber cuántos tienen
es un barrio que está empoderado es un
barrio que está manejando actualmente
sus datos ellos hacen sus propias
encuestas
más de 23 jóvenes son voluntarios de las
naciones unidas- del barrio han tocado
las puertas han visto qué era lo que
pasaba pero lo interesante de esto y en
esta imagen es que la tecnología entra
pero entra no como parte principal sino
como una ayuda y una herramienta
actualmente se encuentran haciendo sus
propias encuestas
se está viendo con las universidades
cómo podemos potenciar para que ellos
puedan estudiar y trabajar
entonces al final creamos y les damos
mucho valor a lo que es este barrio ya
la ciudadanía porque ellos pueden
manejar sus datos datos en evidencia
poder decir no quiero más calles
asfaltadas o cambio de basureros
necesito 20 luces porque porque tengo
seguridad ciudadana me está complicando
tengo problemas con alcoholismo con los
jóvenes
se puede ir a ayudarlos para las
demandas y el trabajo
y ahí nos hacemos otra pregunta en el
laboratorio
bueno en el laboratorio no hacemos
preguntas todos los días muchas
respuestas pero nos hacemos muchas
preguntas y la segunda era cómo podemos
hacer que la ciudadanía
pueda ayudarnos a levantar datos
sabemos que los datos son cruciales para
una política pública para una evidencia
de lo que yo estoy haciendo para poder
trabajar
la pandemia nos ha ayudado a eso nos ha
ayudado a que podemos acelerar esto que
el tema digital ya está adelante y que
tenemos que seguir y hay que potenciarlo
ahí es donde crea donde sale el barrio
el proyecto perdón big data urbano
identificamos que en la ciudad de el
alto la empresa de recojo de basura
trabaja al día
alrededor de 25.000 kilómetros día
10.000 km día de camionetas y 5 mil
kilos 2000 kilos 2000 puntos 5
kilómetros de los barrenderos y
barrenderas que pasa en la ciudad
esos heroicos y protagonistas de la
pandemia que mientras estábamos en casa
de ellos limpiaban las calles los
identificamos como que los que más
recorrían la ciudad
creamos una aplicación
donde esta aplicación
sube los datos trabaja en tiempo real la
evidencia que lo que está pasando y que
más y que mejor de ellos que tienen el
día a día en eso entonces acá tenemos la
implementación en uno de los carros
basureros donde sabemos dónde hay un
tope donde hay un bache y ellos
recolectan los datos masivos
capacitamos alrededor de 25 barrenderas
y barrenderos que actualmente se
encuentran subiendo datos
para poder trabajar esto hemos
identificado que son datos pueden ser
muchos
y los comenzamos a dividir que
necesitamos y ahí entra el segundo ente
la alcaldía
qué necesitan qué datos podemos ver
ahora para mejorar la ciudad y
comenzamos con semanas temáticas de
infraestructura de salud y educación
vamos a ir por lo que es el comercio
informal
estos datos que tenemos nos dan datos
ubicación todas las necesidades que se
está teniendo el que se tienen y todas
las oportunidades que pueden tener
y cambiamos el modo de entender de que
todos nosotros tenemos que ayudar que
los datos y la inteligencia colectiva no
tiene que ser separado por áreas tiene
que ser hecho por todos
actualmente nos encontramos diseñando
todo lo que es la
estamos en la recopilación de todos los
datos que estamos trabajando y estos
datos con la tecnología van a entrar a
un machine learning para poder cambiar
la política pública para saber por qué
lado tenemos que ir por donde puede
crecer la ciudad la tecnología que nos
tiene que ayudar a poder seguir ir hacia
adelante
con tantas preguntas que nos hacíamos el
laboratorio trabaja con una metodología
que es el sentir que es el saber que es
el ir abajo salir del escritorio y
trabajar es el explorar
explorar datos que no sabemos cómo
podemos tomar los que tenemos que
innovar que tenemos que pensar cómo
podemos ver que dónde están esos datos
exploramos y los experimentamos
experimentamos con el público privado
con las startups que tienen buenas ideas
con la ciudadanía con las alcaldías con
el mismo ciudadano que está aportando
con este cambio que creamos con ellos no
creamos como creamos con ellos
volvemos si hay algo que volver a
explorar se vuelve atrás se vuelve
adelante nunca hay un error siempre hay
que volver adelante y atrás y cuando el
experimento y la comienza engranar y
está funcionando se lo escala y esto es
para acelerar lo que queremos hacer en
corto tiempo
algo que ha aprendido en esta pandemia y
en estos meses en mi trabajo es que
realmente hay que salir del escritorio
entender qué es lo que pasa y trabajar
pero trabajar todos juntos porque la
inteligencia la tenemos todos los
contextos lo tenemos todo
gracias
[Aplausos]